et on va tout de suite écoutez le
président russe vladimir poutine sur
l'antenne de france 24 les participants
et les invités du forum économique
nacion international de saint
pétersbourg c'est le vingt cinquième
forum
c'est un moment difficile pour notre
communauté internationale car les
systèmes économiques et leurs principes
se trouve sous menace ou distique le
sieur
connexion commerciales logistiques et
autres qui ont été menacés déjà par la
pandémie déco vides sont menacés de
nouveau aujourd'hui la réputation
commerciale
le manque de confiance entre vis-à-vis
des partenaires sont devenus réalité et
nos partenaires nos anciens partenaires
l'ont fait on on d'ambition et on on
d'illusions politique
aujourd'hui je vous présenterai la
vision de la
russie et de nos dirigeants ce sur la
situation actuelle économique et sur les
perspectives et je vous dirais également
comment la russie prévoit d'agir dans
des conditions économiques qui change
rapidement il y a deux ans quand je
parlais au forum de davos je disais que
l'époque
monde monopolaire est terminée
il a dit cela est terminé malgré toutes
les tentatives de la réserve est de la
conserver même par tous les moyens
possibles c'est un mouvement historique
naturel
garonne et les très difficile de
combiner la variété culturelle
économique avec le seul standard les
standards qu'on essaie d'imposer à
partir ça dans seul centre et le défaut
est contenue
dans les délais jaune que si
seulement si les états forts qu'ils
prennent toutes les décisions cela ne
peut pas
fonctionner
quand toutes les décisions travail
seulement dans un côté seulement quand
on joue seulement dans un sens les états
unis ayant prononcé leur victoire dans
la guerre froide froide se sont vus en
tant que missionnaire de dieu sur la
terre
qui ont les intérêts qui sont considérés
comme sacrés ils n'ont pas remarqué que
pendant les dix dernières années dans le
monde entier deux centres de nouveau
centre puissant se sont développées et
ses centres développent leurs propres
modèles d'institutions et de croissance
économique ils ont droit de défendre
leur souveraineté nationale
il s'agit des processus naturels
il s'agit également de changement
sextonik si dans l'économie mondiale
dans tout le système des relations
internationales
hulot rôle des soldats dynamique ayant
des perspectives et croissants les états
qu'on ne peut plus ignorer je répèterai
ces changements ignominie montant
caractère fondamental est
indéniable je dirais qu'elle est
impossible de rester assez attendre que
tout redevienne comme avant
non cela ne va pas se produire en suisse
mais il semblerait que certains leaders
ou d'états occidentaux
restent
centrées sur leurs illusions ils
s'accrochent aux aidés du passé car il
pense que la domination par l'occident
du système économique mondial est
éternel non et puis simplement la
réalité il essaie de contrer dire le
courant de l'histoire en restant dans
leurs propres illusions en restant dans
l'illusion
d'état de ce qu'on appelle le milliard
d'or et regarde le reste du monde
comment leurs colonies les habitants de
ces pays sont considérés par
comme des hommes disons de deuxième
catégorie
d'où provient leur désir de punir ceux
qui ne rentrent pas dans les rangs qui
ne veulent pas se soumettre et en même
temps aussi ils violent leurs propres
principes éthiques et met en doute la
souveraineté de certains états par
exemple la yougoslave et la syrie la
libye l'irak pour n'en nommer que
quelques-uns
on ne sait d'isoler les états qui vont à
l'encontre de leurs opinions même le
sport
même les jeux olympiques même la culture
sont interdits sous le motif de leur
provenance
et ses lames cela va aussi pour les
sanctions à l'égard de la russie qui
sont infondées et qui sont pas
raisonnables leur rapidité est
incroyable ces sanctions sont sans
précédent et ils veulent tout simplement
faire s'écrouler l'économie du russe et
il essaye de frapper les finances
l'industrie et le niveau de vie des
russes mais il n'y arrive pas c'est
évident
n'y arrive pas les entrepreneurs les
organes de pouvoir ont travaillé des
façons une jauge les citoyens ont montré
leur unité également nous avons réussi à
stabiliser les marchés financiers
les marchés bancaires nous avons
réinjecter des liquidités sur le marché
nous avons assuré la stabilité des
industries nous avons assuré les lieux
de travail pour nos travailleurs et donc
les pronostics catastrophique de ce
trente ans n'ont pas eu lieu mais nous
comprenons d'où venaient ses prédictions
concernant les courbes de l'art qui
allait augmenter
les prédictions concernant l'écroulement
de notre économie c'était une tentative
de faire pression psychologique sur un
autre un milieu de deux business par
ailleurs certains de nos business matin
le business et leurs dirigeants ont
succombé à ce type de prédictions
catastrophistes cependant je voudrais
souligner encore une fois que nous
devons être honnêtes et extrêmement
réaliste dans nos conclusions et nous
devons croire en nos forces c'est très
important nous sommes des personnes
fortes et nous pouvons faire face à
n'importe quel défi nous pouvons
résoudre n'importe quelle tâche
l'histoire de plusieurs millénaires de
notre pays le dit
[Applaudissements]
après les sanctions sans précédent nous
avons réussi à mitiger l'inflation
aujourd'hui elle ne fait que
16,7 pour cent et qu'on savait notre
situation économique se stabilise nos
finances sont stables je ferai quelques
comparaisons avec d'autres régions oh
oui bien sûr on pourrait dire que
16,7 énorme du point de vue global mais
dans cette situation là c'est peut-être
pas si négative que cela nous avons eu
en profite site de 3
milliards de roubles et donc cette
situation positive avec un autre budget
national a plus que je cadre on plie les
prévisions que nous avons
donc nous avons eu
la possibilité de re constituer et
refonder non marché interne je vous ai
déjà dit nous avons pris des mesures
spécifiques et très ciblées pour
réinjecter des liquidités
dans l'activité de nos compagnies et
tout ceci dans le deuxième trimestre de
cette année et aujourd'hui les
entreprises nationales ont beaucoup plus
de souplesse pour leur fonctionnement
pendant le troisième trimestre en ce qui
concerne les paiements d'assurance
ils pourront être
regardés également et on pourra le faire
pendant 12 mois à partir de mois de juin
de l'année prochaine nous avons
également baisser les taux d'hypothèque
au mois de mai qui représente 9% nous
avons prolongé le programme
de de
soutien de cette aubaine pour permettre
aux russes de continuer à investir
dire dans l'immobilier et ensuite
également les taux d'intérêt des banques
russes continuent à descendre notre
banque centrale continue à descendre son
taux d'intérêt et je propose de
descendre encore une fois le taux
d'intérêt concernant les hypothèques
jusqu'à 7%
mais
pourquoi je voulais attirer votre
attention cette que l'action des
programmes initiés
durera la même a
le même temps donc et se terminera à la
fin de cette année donc les sommes des
crédits maximum en reste 12 millions de
roubles pour moscou et saint pétersbourg
et 10 millions de roubles pour le reste
de notre pays nous avons bien évidemment
attiré plus de crédits pour les
investissements à long terme et
notamment genou nous devons
soutenir les
structures économiques et nous devons le
sortir de du domaine de soutien étatique
vers les structures financières et nous
allons à louer 120 milliards de roubles
pour le soutien de ses programmes ce qui
permettrait de nouvelles lignes de
crédit pour des nouveaux
projets pour endémie trillions de
roubles je vous disais que le blitzkrieg
économique contre la russie n'a pas eu
de succès et comme vous savez
larmes à de sanctions en fait elle va
dans les deux sens et cela est démontré
par
les quelques année
dernière
et cette arme elles menacent également
ce qu'ils inventent et ceux qui
l'utilisent nous savons que parmi les
leaders des états eurofer haut niveau
en forme elle des perspectives assez
inquiétantes sont discutées et ils
disent que ce non seulement contre la
russie qu'elles vont
établir ce type de sanctions contre tous
ceux qui sont contre leurs politiques y
compris les membres d union européenne
mais ils ont déjà menacé leurs propres
économies à nantes réduisant ses
sanctions nous avons déjà vu
comment les problèmes économiques et
sociaux se sont renforcés et accentué en
union européenne et aux etats-unis nous
voyons à quel point le niveau de vie des
européens
diminue nous avons fait quelques calculs
et des pulls début des sanctions
les parts de l'union européenne pourrait
constituer 400 millions de dollar vers
l'année prochaine ce sont les
conséquences directes des sanctions et
ce sont les européens
qui vont payer ce prix là maintenant
l'inflation dans les états membres de
l'union européenne a dépassé 1 20% je
vous ai donné les chiffres concernant
notre inflation et le niveau d'inflation
de l'union européenne ils ne mènent pas
d'opérations militaires et vous voyez je
veux aussi le niveau d'inflation est le
plus haut depuis les 40 dernières années
nous avons déjà réussi à procéder à
l'indexation de nos salaires ainsi que
de nom
une retraite pour assurer le niveau de
vie minimal des couches les plus
défavorisées de la population et nous
avons réussi également à sauter hier
notre système bancaire bien évidemment
nous comprenons que la situation
actuelle est toujours difficile pour nos
citoyens et je remercie que nos citoyens
ont fait retourner beaucoup d'argent
dans les banques
vu ses taux d'intérêt assez élevé nous
savons que l'inflation actuelle mange
une grande partie de mur une économie de
nos citoyens nous savons aussi que les
pertes pour les compagnies européennes
sont énormes
nous savons que l'économie européenne
perd de la rapidité de sa croissance de
façon systémique pour plusieurs années
ils ont des problèmes systémiques
profond qui sont là et qui vont croître
j'en ai également parlé à davos les
conséquences directes des politiques
européennes actuelles ce héros l'examen
l'exacerbation de
cassure de fracture qui existe dans
leurs sociétés et entre les différentes
couches de leur société
aujourd'hui cette contradiction se sont
étoffées mises sous le tapis mais quand
on regarde ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
en europe quelles sont les forces qui
arrivent au pouvoir
juste
incroyable parce que en fait ce sont
encore des parties
frère
parce que
on ne change que les
les participants mais le
met le sens des politiques ne changent
pas on voit l'augmentation de grands
populiste on remarque
la dégradation des élites qui pourrait
entraîner leur changement
aujourd'hui nous voyons que les
nouvelles
formations rassembla beaucoup aux
anciennes donc on peut faire semblant
que tout ce passe bien
et que ce ne sont que le prix à payer
pour l'unité ne servirait à rien
aujourd'hui l'union européenne a perdu
sa souveraineté économique et politique
d'autant plus qu'il réponde aux demandes
extérieures en menaçant leur propre
business et leur propre économie la
situation actuelle est la situation
économique actuelle difficile n'est pas
le résultat de ces quelques derniers
mois bien sûr que non ce n'est pas le
résultat de l'opération mais les terres
spécial que la russie eut même dans you
don't basse le dire c'est vraiment
déplacé la responsabilité
ailleurs en fait la situation actuelle a
été créé il y à bien longtemps
le monde se trouvent dans cette
situation
à cause de la politique de la du
soi-disant g7 qui ont fait la politique
d'accumulation de dette pendant de
nombreuses années ce qui est s'est
encore aggravée pendant l'épidémie d'e
on avait russes encore en 2020 quand la
demande et l'offre pour les services
avaient diminué et on peut se demander
quel est le rôle de l'opération spéciale
au donbass danton cela au camp parce que
tout simplement les dirigeants des pays
occidentaux ont commencé à imprimer de
l'argent pour essayer de couvrir les
déficits absolument
incomparable
ces tendances deux dernières années la
masse d'argent aux états unis a augmenté
de
38%
c'est la fête 5,9 en
trillions de dollars et l'ia que
quelques paix dans le monde qui ont le
pib qui dépassent ce nombre est la masse
d'argent en union européenne a également
augmenté énormément augmenté juste
devant % à peu près et j'entendais plus
en plus dernièrement et vous me
pardonnerez parce que
je n'aime pas
faire beaucoup d'éloges
non au même mais en fait les autres
occidentaux ils disent
ils parlent de l'inflation
poutine mais je pense que toutes les
personnes que savent réfléchir qu'on lui
prenne à ce qui se passe réellement car
l'opération militaire spéciale au
donbass n'a rien à voir avec
l'augmentation des prix sur les denrées
alimentaires et énergétiques et ainsi de
suite cette situation est seulement la
conséquence de graves erreurs dans la
gestion des dirigeants des états unis et
de l'union européenne
bien évidemment notre opération
militaire spécial à jouer un certain
rôle dans ce processus mais ce processus
avait déjà eu lieu et ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pour eux est une espèce de
décharge
source dire qu'en fait ce ne sont pas
eux qui sont responsables
de l'utilisation
de moyens
financiers qui n'étaient pas gérées
convenablement
ni beaucoup son talent et ses
centaines et des milliers de notes de
banques qui ont été imprimés personne ne
voulait réfléchir quand ils l'ont fait
aujourd'hui il voit qu'il ne leur reste
que très peu si en 2019 l'importation
aux états unis faisaient 250 milliards
de dollars par mois aujourd'hui cela
fait 350 milliards de dollars et les
très intéressant que l'augmentation à
représenter jusqu'à 40 %
proportionnellement
c'est la correspond à l'augmentation de
la masse d'argent imprimés qui a été
observé pendant ce deux dernières années
en fait qu'ils sont allés sur les
marchés des pays tiers je voudrais aussi
ajouter que les états unis étaient des
fournisseurs en portant des produits
alimentaires sur les produits mondiaux
et l'état fiers de leurs traditions
d'agriculture de fermiers qui était par
ailleurs exemplaire même couru mais
aujourd'hui le rôle des états unis
d'amérique a changé de façon
fondamentale
parce que aujourd'hui les états unis
d'amérique se sont
transformées en une importateurs pur et
dur car elle achète les denrées
alimentaires dans le monde entier et il
continue à augmenter leurs importations
mais la situation est encore plus
flagrant dans les pays de l'union
européenne
et ils ont créé actuellement une vague
de pénurie et d'inflation pendant les
deux dernières années
quasiment toutes les denrées ont
augmenté dans le monde entier les
matières premières mais surtout les
produits alimentaires bien évidemment
les états unis et les pays de l'europe
occidentale continue à emporter mais le
salle d'eau entre les importations et
les exportations a changé car
l'importation représentait 3 13
milliards de plus que les exportations
encore mois de février de cette année
les index de
d'importation de produits alimentaires
faisait 50 % est tandis que l'inde
obsession de d'importation de tous les
produits a plus que doublé pourquoi
échanger les marchandises contre les
dollars et les euros qui perd de la
valeur en imax ou ce qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire
et donc l'économie
de
l'économie qui n'est pas réel en fait va
être changée par une économie qui est
basée sur les réalités
l'argent qui circule aujourd'hui perd de
sa valeur
de 10% par an un peu près d'autant plus
cet argent peut être confisqué ou volé
si par exemple les états unis n'aime pas
quelque chose dans la politique d'un
état ou d'un emprunt peut-on simplement
le priver de cet argent
car vous savez que plusieurs états
gardent leur side up financier en
dollars ça n'est qu'une analyse
objective vous savez que dans les années
qui viennent nous allons commencer un
mécanisme d anvers une conversion des
monnaies existantes
et les autres pays vont le faire
cela va concerner les produits
alimentaires les matières premières et
ainsi de suite cela va augmenter encore
plus l'ambition dieu dollar concernant
l'europe
bien évidemment l'augmentation de
prix actuels et la politique actuelle
qui n'est pas très visionnaire vont
continuer à augmenter
les prix sur les sources d'énergie et
cela va continuer je vais me répéter et
il ya bien
plus il ya longtemps bien avant le début
de notre opération militaire spéciale
ces prix ont augmenté
donc il ne faut pas nous accuser de cela
lors politique a également entraîné la
diminution de production
d'engrais notamment d'engrais azotés les
prix globaux
de sur les engrais azotés ont augmenté
de 70% pendant la dernière année
aujourd'hui on continue à bloquer la
logistique de livraisons d'engrais de
que la russie et la biélorussie la
situation devient de plus en plus
difficile et il est très facile de
prévoir ce que ça va entraîner cela va
entraîner la diminution de production de
produits alimentaires ce qui veut dire
que c'est la recrée des pénuries ce que
les prix vont augmenter encore et encore
et que ce sont les pays les plus pauvres
qui vont souffrir
et tout cela et se crée par les états
unis et les bureaucrates européens je me
répète encore une fois cela n'a pas été
créé il ya quelques mois et à cause de
la russie comme certaine sa vision que
nous démagogues la firme ah non
évidemment
ce serait peut-être un moment agréable
pour nous de savoir que nous sommes
aussi puissant que nous sont capables de
changer la situation dans le monde a en
tête toi ce serait peut-être
flatteur mais cela ne correspond pas à
la réalité cette situation elle
nourrissait pendant des années elle
était créée par le manque de vision de
ceux qui prenaient des décisions
concernant les émissions financières
pour changer les flux financiers pour
créer encore plus de déficit et pour
provoquer des catastrophes humanitaires
dans certaines régions c'est encore une
fois cette politique
de et pour coloniale qui est devenu
beaucoup plus
fine car elle est très difficile de
comprendre du premier regard ce qui se
passe réellement
aujourd'hui il est très important
d'assurer la survie des états qui ont
qui sont dépendants de la production des
autres pour leur propre survie la russie
est capable d'assurer le nombre
suffisant de denrées alimentaires et la
quantité suffisante de darna
élémentaires pour notre marché intérieur
mais nous pouvons également augmenter
les exportations
nous allons exporter dans les pays qui
ont le plus besoin de nourriture là où
il ya le risque de famine il s'agit des
états africains et du moyen orient
mais bien évidemment il y a des
difficultés qui apparaissent et qu'ils
ne sont pas liés avec non position vous
savez les américains ont introduit les
sanctions puis les européens les ont
commencé et puis les américains en fait
on change d'avis parce qu'ils ont
compris
où cela allait mener mais les autres
n'ont pas
compris ce qui allait se passer mais
nous ne comprenons que c'était pas
intelligent mais c'est très difficile
maintenant pour eux de faire marche
arrière
reprenons la russie est prête à
contribuer à la gestion l équilibrage
des marchés mondiaux et nous saluons
bien évidemment l'ouverture et va au
dialogue de nos collègues de l'onu et
à l'issue de ces pourparlers nous allons
peut-être pouvoir
de créer des conditions favorables pour
l'équilibrage de la situation économique
mondiale actuelle je ne peux pas ne pas
toucher la question des exportations
ukrainiennes à
des produits alimentaires craignant sur
les marchés mondiaux mais ce n'est pas
nous qui avons mines et les ports nous
n'empêcherons pas à cette exportation là
d'après les
d'après les calculs américaine il s'agit
de
six millions de tonnes de blé
5 millions de tonnes
de maïs qui sont empêchés d'être
exporté au niveau de marché mondial ce
n'est pas un ce n'est pas en nombre
énorme et par ailleurs vous pouvez le
faire via la biélorussie via la pologne
à la roumanie il ya plusieurs façon
d'exporter ces denrées donc encore une
fois ce n'est pas de notre
responsabilité
c'est de la responsabilité des pouvoirs
qui sont en place à kiev et ils doivent
prendre ces décisions
de façon
indépendante bon il y à un autre
possibilité c'est que seb les servent de
paiement pour les livraisons d armes à
ce qui ce serait ce qui serait très
triste maintenant les institutions
internationales
ne fonctionne pas correctement c'était
très difficile de conclure quelques
accords us que ce soit aujourd'hui
la décision de la russie de mener cette
opération militaire spéciale a été
difficile mais elle était indispensable
c'était la décision d'un pays souverain
est ce qui est d'ailleurs
inscrit dans les statuts de leurs élus
donc la russie
voulait tout simplement défendre sa
souveraineté vous savez que
les russes est objet de génocide pendant
plusieurs années
il y a vous savez que l'occident ne
faisaient que augmenter la présence
militaire sur le territoire ukrainien
concernant les
concernant les situations économiques
des habitants
d'el est des le traîne ça n'intéressait
personne il met
des sommes énormes d'argent ont été
alloués pour
la russophobie et pour la livraison des
armes aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les défenseurs des territoires ddt et
l'est de l'ukraine luttent pour leurs
droits de définir
ni appartiendra leur avenir et la lutte
contre les pseudo valeurs qu'on essaye
de leur imposer il y en a évidemment
toutes les tous les objectifs de notre
opération militaire serre ont atteint
et longages pour cela et c'est le
courage et l'héroïsme de nos hommes
ainsi que le soutien de notre société
qui donne le soutien à notre armée la
compréhension de la vérité historique
que nous défendons ce qui est de
soutenir et de protéger la souveraineté
de notre état aujourd'hui on 21e siècle
la souveraineté n'est peut être
partielle à elle ne peut qu'être
complète avec toutes les composantes qui
s'ajoutent les unes aux autres donc nous
ne devons pas que défendre notre
identité nationale mais aussi nous
devons promouvoir notre
indépendance économique la construction
des sanctions économiques occidentales a
été construite sur une thèse fossat que
l'économie russe n'est pas sauvé un
homme qu'elle est vulnérable
ils se sont tellement
épris de leurs propres idées de du côté
retardé de l'économie russe qu'ils n'ont
pas
compris
à quel point notre pays a changé pendant
ces quelques dernières années et comment
nous avons changé comment nous avons
travailler sur notre sécurité
macroéconomiques sur notre sécurité
alimentaire
comment nous avons avancé dans le
domaine de notre indépendance financière
bien évidemment la situation actuelle
pose devant nous quelques
défis une par exemple la livraison
de pièces détachées les chaînes
logistiques sont
brisées mais en même temps ces défis
nous donne de nouvelles possibilités
nous en parlons souvent mais c'est la
réalité
c'est une stimulation assez importante
pour développer notre potentiel
économique
scientifique intellectuel
bien évidemment il est impossible de
résoudre une tâche d'une telle
complexité
rapidement nous devons travailler dans
une perspective à long terme et en
réalisant les plans de développement de
l'économie
de notre pays
ne sont pas changé il n'y a que les
façons de les atteindre acquis de change
et je voudrais touché quelques
poids important pour le développement de
notre pays premier point c'est
l'ouverture nous avons toujours visé le
partenariat
d'égal à égal
et vous savez ceux qui sont dépendants
cherche toujours les responsables pour
leur propre à rob l'ema et dépendent de
leur suggéra
vous savez que la russie ne va pas aller
ouvert l'auto
isolement nous allons continuer à
chercher des partenariats avec tous ceux
qui veulent continuer à collaborer avec
nonce est une majorité d'états du monde
tout le monde le savait je ne dirai rien
de nouveau
si je rappelle que tous ceux qui veulent
travailler avec la russie ce bis des
fonctions ouverte parfois même les
menace ouverte de la part des états unis
parfois en tel chantage ne vaut pas
grand chose compte des vrais laideur
dirige
tel ou tel pays et qui est que ces
leaders comprennent où sont leurs
véritables intérêts et la russie va
continuer à augmenter la coopération
avec ces états bien évidemment nous
allons continuer à coopérer avec les
entreprises occidentales qui malgré tous
les bâtons qu'on le met dans les roues
continue à collaborer avec nous
nous allons créer une nouvelle
plateforme de paiement indépendante pour
augmenter et
faciliter les structures logistiques
nous développons les nouveaux couloirs
logistique nous construisons les
nouveaux ports des cargaisons
notamment dans les mers nordiques ainsi
clé dans le bassin de la mer caspienne
et de la mer noire ce qui permettrait
également de communication avec les pays
de l'asie centrale et du proche orient
ce n'est pas que le commerce
international qui est important mais
c'est aussi la coopération humanitaire
sportives et culturelles qui emporte
dans l'établissement et le renforcement
de ses
contacts le deuxième prix sip de notre
développement durable ce sont les
libertés économiques
chaque initiative a privé qui va viser
le bien être de la russie doit être
soutenue la pandémie nous a montré à
quel point la flexibilité et les
libertés économiques sont importantes
car
et le possible d'être concurrentiels sur
le marché mondial en s'adaptant aux
réalités changeantes
il est très difficile et très important
d'assurer
le développement de l'économie en
s'appuyant sur les business privé vous
savez que nous avions un moratoire sur
les vérifications de peptides des moyens
de l'entreprise jusqu'à jeux 2018 nous
l'avons
étendue jusqu'à l'année 2001 21 et vous
savez que nous avons encore diminuer les
vérifications de tous les représentants
de business
privé à condition qu'il ne soit pas
dangereux pour l'environnement jusque là
donc nous vérifions de moins en mois
nous
disent le privé nous les avons diminué
de 6 fois l'année dernière pourquoi
parce que
parce que en fait grâce à ce niveau de
confiance que nous leur accordons nos
entreprises sont devenues beaucoup plus
responsable c'est la montre que les
entreprises russes sont devenus matures
responsable nous avons encore une
motivation
d'augmenter
si le niveau de confiance envers nos
business nous avons décidé tout
simplement d'abolir le système de
vérification
de toutes les entreprises privées russes
qui ne sont pas liés avec la menace
potentielle à la santé et tout le monde
le comprend risque on peut adopter une
approche orientée
haut risque et je demande nos dirigeants
des structures économiques
d'élaborer les programmes à
qui correspond au smic pour minimiser
les
malversations et d'autres
violations nous sommes en train de
travailler sur les législations
économique et sur le droit les articles
du droit pénal relatifs à l'activité
économique
dans l'avenir le plus nous
allons adopter la législation
et alléger la législation concernant les
violations fiscale en gros nous devons
de façon prudente mais de façon
appuyée
décriminaliser les
infractions économiques
c'est une question très
très très délicate car aujourd'hui nous
sommes face à un comportement il
légitime de nos partenaires occidentaux
et qui font en sorte à ce que les
business russes sont obligés de ne pas
respecter les accords mais nous
comprenons bien que et ils ne le font
que parce qu'ils sont
ils n'ont pas d'autre choix
il est important de réfléchir aussi
assouplir les
les sanctions concernant
et concernant les sanctions fiscales
j
les législations doivent correspondre
aux réalités
et nous travaillons là-dessus depuis
depuis
2016 notamment dans le domaine de
l'inflation et enfants nous devons
revoir
les
délais de détention provisoire
envers les
les acteurs économiques
quand les dirigeants sont en détention
les entreprises sont obligées
d'arrêter leur activité
plusieurs personnes perdent leur emploi
la réputation des entreprises sont
menacées donc je demande à tous les
responsables de mettre fin à ces
pratiques
et je demande au gouvernement
de préparer ensemble avec la cour
suprême de préparer les amendements
correspondants dans la législation
concernant le conseil de sécurité
nous devons également travailler sur les
affaires criminelles qui sont ouvertes
et qui ne sont pas menées à bien
qu'est-ce qui est derrière tout cela
certaines affaires sont ouvertes sans
fondations ou bien sont utilisés pour
effectuer la pression sur tel ou tel
acteur économique nous allons discuter
de ce sujet encore une fois et plus en
détails en automne aux formes douces le
rôle
important pour créer et
une
pour créer une atmosphère propice à
l'activité économique est discutée lors
de ce forum de sang petersburg
notre agence des initiatives
stratégiques
effectué une évaluation constante des
acteurs économiques nationaux
et aujourd'hui la région de moscou a
meaux est monté elle était au à la
huitième classe et maintenant élèves à
la troisième place la région de toula de
sakhaline saint pétersbourg
bachkortostan ont également augmenté
aussi les régions de cours ghana qui a
augmenté de 36 position la région de
perm et d'altaï et ingouches et y
correspond en correspondance de 36 24 %
je voudrais remercier
nos collègues dans les régions pour leur
travail efficace
bien évidemment
notre gouvernement fédéral
doit soutenir les initiatives
économiques des personnes particulières
surtout dans les régions éloignées
il s'agit également
de programmes de production et de vente
de produits écologiques
sur notre marché intérieur
il est très important de créer de
nouvelles possibilités
de créer jeu déterra
logistique
électronique et il est très important de
moderniser également le fonctionnement
de la poste russe ella important d'aider
les petites et moyennes entreprises les
entrepreneurs
individuels
obtenir les nouvelles
compétences nous allons focaliser les
petites sur les petites villes et nous
allons focaliser sur le développement
des petites et moyennes en moyenne aux
entreprises je voudrais m'adresser
aujourd'hui aux dirigeants de grandes
entreprises aux au gestionnaire chers
collègues leurs amis
en succès véritable le sentiment
de dignité et de respect vis-à-vis de
soi-même sa neuvième seulement quand ton
lit notre propre avenir assez quel
avenir de nos enfants avec l'avenir de
notre voilà donc pour ce long extrait du
discours de vladimir poutine au forum
économique de saint-pétersbourg